250 personnes ont répondu à l'appel de
vincent di tutto cet après midi
certaines un lys à la main lisse comme
les initiales de liam yumi et sophie
disparue depuis trois semaines
maintenant
dans le cortège des amis et proches de
la famille sophie est une amie je la
connais depuis revient environ cinq ans
mon fils était dans la même classe que
yumi donc pour moi c'était une évidence
d'être ici aujourd'hui est ce que si
vous la connaissiez est ce que est ce
que vous pouvez comprendre cette
disparition est ce que c'est elle peut
être expliquer votre avis
pour moi les mecs pin explicable on
comprend pas on voudrait avoir les
réponses à nos questions
pourquoi je connais vinson depuis le
collège
je suis papa aussi donc pour être
solidaires avec lui dans cette épreuve
au bout d'une heure de marche
silencieuse dans le centre ville le
cortège s'arrête devant la mairie puis
le père prend la parole on reste
mobilisé s'il vous plaît restez là aussi
voilà on a une banderole si vous pouvez
l'affiché dans une manifestation
sportive ou artistique et les
disponibles on voit là on continue on
reste debout et indiens de cause merci
merci à vous ça fait du bien d'être
soutenu ça c'est clair quoi je serai
tout seul ne serait perdu
il faut être là il faut être debout il
faut montrer l'exemple
voilà je pars que si je laisse tomber
les gens les stands mais aussi par cette
mobilisation la famille souhaite aussi
marquer une nouvelle étape en demandant
l'aide des opérateurs téléphoniques pour
diffuser la vie de recherche à ses
abonnés on demande pas 20 ou 30 ms un
seul un seul à tous leurs abonnés
et là on couvrira 75 à 80% de la france
on multiplierait nos chances par 10 15
ou 20 millions dé retrouver parce que là
à 20 km 10 il ya des gens qui ne sont au
courant
l'enquète elle se poursuit et les
disparus ont été signalés récemment dans
le sud de la france près d'aubagne
mais la présence là-bas de sophie liam
et yumi n'a pas encore été confirmée